the four fundamental forces of nature  gravity electromagnetism and the strong  and weak nuclear forces now scientists  have blasted neutrons through a crystal  of silicon  to create waves like waves crashing on a  beach helping physicists hunt for a new  fundamental force of nature a so-called  fifth force  [Music]  of the force it binds the galaxy  together now physicists know that there  may be other forces in addition to  gravity electromagnetism and the nuclear  forces now if we were to observe a new  force it could answer the most  fundamental questions  ranging from the nature of dark matter  to the nature of dark energy